people the national security circles
talk about having a belly button to push
a person who's important enough to get
something done you push it happens like
say if we're worried about an Ebola
pandemic we don't have a belly button
for that but we used to in the late
1990s Bill Clinton read about tropical
viruses like Ebola which was discovered
in the 1970s he says fear of an outbreak
kept him up at night so he installed on
the national security council somebody
dedicated solely to bio defense a belly
button 2001 George W Bush gets rid of
the special assistant for bio defense
then after the anthrax attacks he
recreates the position and rehires the
same guy to fill it the belly button
returns then in 2009 Barack Obama
reorganizes the National Security
Council gets rid of the special
assistant for bio defense no belly
button every administration has to
relearn the same lesson this seems like
a bureaucratic chair dance but it has
real consequences back when there was a
guy in charge of bio defense at the
White House every year he made every
department run a simulation for pandemic
influenza and he gave out grades but
none of this planning has actually
happened since 2009 in 2012 a bill in
the house would have recreated that
chair in the National Security Council
and it would have created a national bio
defense plant it didn't pass we still
don't have a special assistant to the
president for bio defense now we see Tom
Frieden on the TV a lot he's the head of
the Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention but the CDC doesn't do
logistics and it doesn't do medical care
friedens job is just to know about the
virus so for the last five years no one
close to the president has had bio
defense as a full-time job there's been
no planning no report cards no grades if
it seems like we don't know how to deal
with the possibility of an Ebola
pandemic it's because once again we're
making it up as we go
Oh